vous évoquez le rôle joué par le
président turc recep tayyip erdogan dont
le monde arabe dans le monde musulman
alors que un peu partout dans ce monde
arabe et ces derniers jours se sont
multipliés des manifestations contre
emmanuel macron notamment ce qui
pointait du doigt ce sont les propos
qu'il a tenus lors de l'hommage national
rendu à samuel pâtit le chef de l'état
qui a simplement défendu le droit à la
liberté d'expression et le droit à
caricaturer absolument ce qui est mal
compris dans le monde musulman c'est que
le droit à caricaturer ne signifie pas
que les français apprécient ces
caricatures la fin je veux dire une
grande majorité de français ne rit pas à
gorge déployée quand il voit le prophète
où jésus ou le pas ou qui siègent
caricaturer simplement ils veulent que
celui qui a envie de caricaturer puisse
le faire et que sa vie ne soit pas mise
en danger pour autant est ce ce principe
là qui nous paraît complètement évidente
france barrée offensant pour une large
partie de la population musulmane
mondiale parce que le blasphème est une
réalité c'est à dire que la notion de
sacré qui a été très largement dans les
siècles en france dans l'histoire de
france
travailler combattu discuter cette
notion de sacré a gardé un sens très
fort en islam est la figure du prophète
est sacrée et donc ne peut pas être
touchée ni même dessiné donc on a une
incompréhension de base ensuite il ya
une volonté de puissance donc il ya une
volonté pour erdogan qui est des
intérêts en méditerranée qui est déjà
historiquement face à la grèce et face à
emmanuel macron qui a pris position en
faveur de la grèce en situation de
tension avec le président français a
trouvé là une occasion de légitimer
auprès de son peuple et j'allais dire
même auprès de toute la classe
la communauté de laghman de la région du
moyen-orient de légitimer la l'ennemi
parce que c'est finalement de cette
façon là que le djihad devient légitime
c'est en disant voilà le mécréant ils
n'attaquent pas simplement le pays
n'attaque pas simplement les
institutions houle ou le hulu le cadre
général
ils attaquent l'islam et il attaque le
prophète en particulier et c'est ce qui
a été repris en iran en caricaturant
emmanuel macron sous forme de diable et
c est ce qui c est ce que vous avez dit
ce qui s'est répandue finalement dans
toute la région où on ne comprend pas
cette volonté de la france qui n'est pas
une volonté de la france mais cette
volonté de la france de caricaturé le
prophète en réalité nous sommes dans une
guerre de civilisation il faut relire le
texte de samuel huntington de 1993 qui
est un un texte absolument admirable où
il explique que les guerres du unième
siècle seront des guerres qui auront
pour base un 10 ans us culturel nous
sommes exactement dans ce cadre